the celebration fit for a third term in
office incumbent Chief Minister Arvind
Kejriwal and supporters of armed army or
the common man party jubilant as they
hear their victorious the people of
Delhi have sent a message they have
voted for people who built health
centers who have given you 24 by 7
electricity it's a beginning of a new
kind of politics and this is great for
India cater for a campaign focusing on
development education and healthcare
this is a great win for mr. Kejriwal
because he really met all the promises
he made to the people of Delhi and we
are very happy that kg Vols team has
worked for us supporters said that the
common man party's campaign had
resonated with voters rather than that
of the BJP that had focused on ending
the protests against the citizenship law
including in the New Delhi neighborhood
of Shaheen bird this is not a win for
Hindu no for Muslims know for sure
handbag this is not a win for Pakistan
this is a good win this is a win for a
party with good intentions the Election
Commission banned two BJP politicians
from campaigning after one compared
protesters to rapists and murderers and
said the demonstrators were determined
to make India a Muslim country another
politician said protesters should be
shot there were two shootings against
protesters in one week in New Delhi
after those comments were made the BJP
says its campaign was successful despite
the losses everybody knows that martyrs
in the party stands for nationalism and
if there was any kind of rejection then
from 2015 our chair is already showing
an upsurge of 10% how is that a
rejection the biggest loser was India's
oldest political party the Congress it
ruled the country for nearly 50 years
after independence from British rule in
1947 but in a repeat of its performance
in the 2015 election it didn't win a
single seat
it is a great day for activists turned
politician arvind kejriwal who's once
again stopped the BJP from winning in
the capital the party hasn't been in
power in Delhi for 22 years and has lost
most of the state elections in the past
18 months those losses are an indication
that campaigning around resonating on al
Jazeera